un passionné de musique mon ami ça je
sais je suis le droit de théâtre tout le
temps mais toi tu fais tout hein tu on
te voit dans tous les spectacles c'est
formidable d'être comme ça et j'ai
toujours écrit des chansons j'ai
toujours écrit les bouquins Enrico
Macias Michel Torr Carlos Richard Dewi
est-il gay et même Laurie
récemment et donc voilà c'est c'est
cette passion là qui un jour a fait
qu'un un bouquin qui parlait de chanson
est arrivé sur le bureau de William
Leymergie qui cherchait un bouche-trou
pour l'été c'est exactement comme ça que
j'étais embauché et c'est vrai que
parfois on peut le dire à la télé ça
surtout l'été en général il me l'a dit
avec avec tout l'humour
toute la gentillesse et toute la
bienveillance de vous il m'a dit voilà
j'ai huit chroniques à vous proposer
pour l'été moi je sortais de chez
Jacques Martin où je faisais mon métier
de hauteur et de voilà de de de hauteur
de sketch pour pour Jacques et puis il
me dit voilà j'ai mis chronique pour
l'été à vous proposer c'est lui
chronique et ben ce sont transformés en
25 ans de collaboration alors c'était en
98 hein tu rejoins la bande de Télématin
sur France 2 spécialiste musical
évidemment et puis c'est au programme et
Sophie Davant aussi effectivement donc
les deux de front durant et durant 20
ans et maintenant depuis le 14 juillet
prochain ça fera 25 ans que je suis
applaudit
c'est une passion ce n'est pas un métier
c'est une activité en parallèle je suis
sur scène en parallèle je fais des
bouquins en parallèle j'écris pour les
autres c'est vraiment une activité en
plus c'est le prolongement c'est vrai
qu'en France on a on a on a un petit peu
de mal on a on a du mal on est quand
même dans le pays du fromage où il faut
vraiment avoir des étiquettes sur les
choses donc quelqu'un qui parle de
chansons n'est pas forcément quelqu'un
qui en fait moi je revendique le droit
de faire les deux et ça se passe plutôt
bien comme par exemple avec le fromage
mais bon c'est une bonne idée mais comme
ça d'être tu es là très présente ça fait
25 ans tu nous l'as dit et tout et tu as
pas envie toi d'animer ta propre
émission ou un jour de passer de l'autre
côté très très honnêtement très très
honnêtement Bernard je suis pas certain
d'en avoir le talent je suis pas certain
d'endroit je suis même pas certain d'en
avoir l'envie moi je suis un passionné
de chanson quand je viens parler le
matin bah en ce moment avec Maya loquet
et Damien Thévenot le samedi matin je
sais pourquoi je suis là je sais enfin
je maîtrise mon sujet je suis pas
certain que j'ai le talent de de lancer
des invités je suis pas le temps je suis
pas certain que j'ai le talent de
d'animer des boules qui sortent et pour
le loto c'est un vrai métier il y a rien
de péjoratif dans ce cas c'est un vrai
métier je suis pas Tab je suis pas
certain d'avoir ce talent là je me
contente de faire ce que je sais faire
ça veut dire de parler de chanson de
chroniquer le talent des autres quand tu
l'as ton en tant que chroniqueur et
d'essayer d'en avoir un petit peu quand
c'est moi qui suis avec quelqu'un que tu
dis ça fait sourire Julien ça te fait
sourire ce qu'il dit Julien Cohen c'est
les boules de l'auto une guerrière
autour de ça c'est quand même assez mais
c'est un vrai salon
et alors toi tu as réussi à t'imposer
comme acheteur hein à faire conclu
évidemment là ça a été très fort alors
là aussi c'est tout de suite une grande
notoriété et toute façon c'est ton
métier de départ ça alors c'est un de
mes métiers de départ effectivement
parce qu'on en a plusieurs on a
plusieurs casquettes mais quand ils sont
venus me chercher parce qu'ils sont
venus me chercher
toi bah c'est-à-dire c'est difficile de
passer à côté de mes boutiques sans
venir me chercher quoi tu vois elles
sont quand même bah oui donc quand il va
opus tu peux voilà si si tu as besoin de
quelqu'un pour faire une émission si tu
es casseurs tu vas passer
obligatoirement par mes boutiques après
on était à une époque où les brocanteurs
les antiquaires n'ont pas envie de faire
cette émission on était que 7 ans
aujourd'hui 125 ou 30 bah parce qu'on
parle c'était nouveau à l'époque alors
moi j'avais fait story avant et puis
c'était tout à fait nouveau et puis les
brocanteurs sont les gens extrêmement
discrets parce que il y a des espèces
parce que voilà etc
et du coup personne voulait y aller donc
on s'est retrouvé à 7 pour tourner on a
été alors justement pardon Julien mais
quand on te dit vous êtes chroniqueur à
la télé c'est quand même encore une
autre métier ça n'a rien à voir c'est
autre chose comment tu es réagiaire ah
bon c'est quoi alors vas-y dis-moi bah
c'est juste attention il va nous
balancer un truc
non mais c'est pas un métier tu fais ton
métier à côté tu viens parler ou étaler
ta connaissance machin etc mais c'est
pas un métier c'est c'est un petit
loisir mais non mais même si tu es
spécialiste dans ton domaine c'est comme
Frédéric dans son domaine c'est quand
même quelque chose d'être chroniqueurs
c'est parler à la télévision c'est mais
c'est n'importe qui ces données son avis
vous pouvez parler oui c'est donner son
avis non c'est notre métier quand même
c'est d'exercer une passion il a l'air
d'abord il y en a qui sont plus ou moins
à l'aise et là c'est pas c'est pas un
métier c'est juste parce que bah tu as
fait du théâtre avant ou tu es un peu
plus à l'aise pas demandé un cachet
alors ah mais j'ai rien demandé
j'ai rien demandé et crois-moi je n'ai
pas besoin de se cacher pour vivre
d'accord on a compris Francesca tu as
fait de moi répondre après vous pensez
évidemment ce que vous voulez mais moi
je pense que chroniqueur au contraire
c'est un métier je pense qu'ici par
exemple Touche pas à mon poste a donné
un peu ses lettres de noblesse au métier
chroniqueur puisque évidemment il y a eu
ça a marché pour certains et d'autres
beaucoup moins mais il a quand même
réussi Cyril Hanouna à sortir des
garçons comme Camille Combal comme
Bertrand Chameroy comme Jean-Luc Lemoine
voilà et à redonner surtout un élan à
d'autres qui marchaient plus je pense à
Julien Courbet qui est revenu ici et qui
a ensuite redevenu une grosse Star sur
M6 donc après on peut dire que
évidemment que c'est du talent pour
certains non mais ça veut dire exposer
un talent mais quand même tu parles de
quelque chose ça peut pas être
complètement vide en plus à côté
après Frédéric mais si on est venu nous
chercher c'est qu'on a quand même voilà
un minimum de métier tu vas pas mettre
un demeurer à la télé une passion que
une passion plutôt
une passion
chroniqueurs
en tout cas moi dans ma bouche c'est pas
du tout et péjoratif c'est que c'est un
truc qu'on fait naturellement parce que
ben parce que entre amis on adore parler
de chanson mais moi ce que je fais à la
télé je le fais pour et pour mes potes
de gratos donc c'est juste oui
effectivement c'est une exposition en
plus exposition qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas à mes estimée au contraire qui était
qui est extrêmement profitable pour le
reste de nos activités mais c'est
vraiment c'est une expertise quelque
chose que l'on pratique couramment que
l'on fait devant une caméra de
télévision Julien toi justement qui est
qui est antiquaire reconnu brocanteur
est-ce que tu aux yeux de la profession
ça t'a pas dévalorisé ou tu as pas eu
des soucis avec ça alors au début ça ne
m'a considérablement dévalorisé ah oui
quand même
à la télé machin etc et puis après il
s'avère que tous ceux effectivement dit
ça en tous envoyés un CV mais bien
évidemment ils ont tous envoyé un cv
pour faire partie de l'équipe d'affaires
conclue pourquoi parce que quand tu es à
la télé moi j'ai fait 1557 émissions
donc c'était beaucoup plus on me l'a
donné quand je suis parti donc on m'a
dit voilà tu as fait 15007 à acheter
2000 objets sur 8000 tu en as pas 25 %.
mais c'est vrai d'ailleurs 113 objets
achetés
bref on a une une énorme notoriété ça
porte d'autres business et ceux qui nous
montrait du doigt ont tous gentiment
mis la main sur sur la chemise en disant
on y va est-ce que vous voudrez bien
nous prendre s'il vous plaît même on vit
bien passé juste une fois alors
justement quand on a un physique un peu
atypique par exemple toi
non pas du tout alors c'est tranquille
je le sais les lunettes c'est ainsi
c'est depuis que j'ai passé à la télé ou
ça toujours été comme ça parce que les
lunettes bleues les lunettes
il y a 9 ans et la télé ça date d'il y a
7 ans ah oui tu avais commencé un peu
avant alors
c'était c'était comment de travailler
avec pierre-jeançon qui lui est quand
même très extravagant et qui a soulevé
beaucoup de polémiques
balancera toujours beaucoup sur beaucoup
de choses Pierre-Jean il a besoin de ça
mais Pierre-Jean c'était c'était
extraordinaire parce qu'on faisait un
duo génial il y avait des alternatives
quelque chose quand même ça va la fête
là tous les deux écoute écoute alors je
suis pas resté longtemps parce qu'il a
eu la connerie comme d'habitude avec
Pierre-Jean de m'inviter à son
anniversaire et juste en
face et Jean-Marie Le Pen
donc c'était pas trop ma tasse de thé tu
vois
merde mec tu t'aurais pu me prévenir et
je suis parti 20 minutes après est-ce
que tu pouvais dire tout ce que tu
voulais dans l'émission oui bah oui on
avait un producteur assez génial
Jean-Louis blot
qui qui nous a donné carte blanche pour
tout au moins un certain peut-être pas
tous mais à certains à ceux que sur
lesquels ils se sentait peut-être un peu
plus de potentiel que d'autres et il
nous a dit faites ce que vous voulez
faites-nous rire faites-nous le faites
du suspense faite voilà et c'est pour ça
qu'avec Jean faisais un très beau duo
Frédéric toi on sent que tu es libre de
toute façon et je pense pas qu'on puisse
t'imposer quoi que ce soit une vraie
liberté sincèrement de toute façon le
cahier des charges en tout cas moi celui
que je me suis donné si on n'aime pas
quelqu'un je vois pas pourquoi je vais
prendre du temps d'antenne pour aller
dézinguer quelqu'un ça c'est pas la
c'est pas c'est pas le genre de la
maison et ce temps d'antenne autant le
dire pour faire des coups de cœur et
pour donner des coups de main à des gens
qui en ont besoin c'est plutôt ça donc
franchement il y a aucune il y a alors
toi qui a traversé de nombreux
télématins et de nombreuses émissions tu
as travaillé avec plein de gens oui
parfois on n'aime pas tout le monde avec
lesquels parfois on travaille non c'est
le ouais j'essaie de le dire
délicatement pour essayer d'obtenir
quelque chose mais ça marche pas tous
très très Frédéric regarde Jean-Michel
il est à côté design il a supporte pas
il a envie d'attraper
non très très honnêtement le le vecteur
fin de celui qui a vraiment été qui
était vraiment le le patron pendant des
années et c'était William et franchement
pour ne pas s'entendre avec William il
faut se lever de bonheur non mais il
savait ce qu'il voulait mais franchement
au niveau de la bienveillance au niveau
de la fidélité au niveau de au niveau de
ses équipes et encore et encore
aujourd'hui au niveau de la fidélité ça
fait 5 autres qu'on travaille plus
ensemble mais rendez-vous de l'amitié au
rendez-vous de la fidélité et de la
générosité il est toujours là c'est vrai
ça William c'est sûr voilà
Sophie aussi tu travaillais quelques
quelques 20 ans avec elle
encore encore une fois une fois qu'on
fait bien son boulot une fois qu'on sait
ce pourquoi on est là une fois qu'on a
pas envie de rentrer forcément dans des
querelles à droite ou à gauche c'est
comme partout quand on fait son boulot
et qu'on s'est gardé la bonne distance
je crois qu'on y arrive voilà Julien
c'était qui ton préféré
tu parleras ce soir chez ta mère
je connais sa famille très bien Julien
et quel était ton préféré écoute mon
préféré pour travailler c'était
Pierre-Jean même si on a eu des gros
coups de gueule ensemble
pour travailler oui parce qu'il est
rigolo parce qu'il est rigolo parce
qu'on avait des automatismes parce que
voilà il connaît bien aussi et me
connaître très bien voilà après après il
y avait une belle zone mais
par exemple tu vois
à droite le deuxième le Vincent Vincent
Clément le le producteur c'est un mec
génial c'est un mec génial et très beau
beau gosse marié marié je suis désolé
tu veux tu veux son téléphone on peut se
débrouiller
qui va se marier tu vas te marier
j'avais une question pour vous bien en
fait je me la rumeur circule en ce
moment que Sophie pourrait Sophie Davant
pour écouter pour équitter à faire
conclu il y aurait peut-être soit
Caroline marjoridon soit on ne sait pas
qui pourrait la remplacer est-ce que
vous par exemple ça pourrait vous
intéresser de passer du côté chroniqueur
au côté animateur alors
en l'espace de deux ans deux ans
d'absence sur sur affaire conclue tu
dois répondre oui mais donner
l'impression que tu as envie de dire non
ah d'accord
gros caméra quand l'espace de deux ans
j'ai fait quatre maisons des brocanteurs
c'est à dire j'ai acheté quatre châteaux
pour les transformer en lieu d'accueil
pour des brocanteurs et que à la base
moi je suis pour le business je fais que
du business ça c'est la cerise sur le
gâteau maintenant racheter une boîte de
prod ou racheter une chaîne de télé
pourquoi pas tu vois mais ça c'est un
autre métier dis-moi
[Rires]
si c'est trop cher alors dis-moi c'est
un tremplin alors d'être nicker parce
que c'est depuis que tu es chroniqueurs
c'est pas depuis que je suis chroniqueur
moi j'ai la chance d'avoir introduit
deux de mes boîtes en bourse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et Julien Cohen ok de toi aussi vous
allez lancer des maisons des brocanteurs
en octobre 2021 à Péronne dans
l'ancienne Banque de France puis à
Avalon dans les anciens abattoirs ça
c'est une belle idée et vous avez
inauguré la maison campeurs de
Châteaudun samedi dernier après 8 mois
de travaux les boules bravo
et là son magazine Sinner d'histoire en
Afrique 2022